Hercules it's not only my first 3d film
more importantly it's my first imax film
and i could not be more excited I just
came from the imax theater watched the
film and imax and i can tell you this i
will never see the film as good as it I
just saw it just now I've always wanted
to do an epic sword and sandal film
similar to Cecil B DeMille Spartacus
ben-hur the battle sequences are just
the coolest thing I meant the thousands
of soldiers using the anamorphic frame I
mean it is mind blowing and I was
sitting there literally pinching myself
calling I will never see my feeling
looking better than this even the sound
was nothing like I've ever heard before
the detail and the nuance when you're
watching in an imax all your senses kind
of open up it's just complete eye candy
the most intense visual experience
you can easily done this movie in a in a
CGI kind of green screen world but I
wanted the actors to walk on the set and
feel like they were in ancient Greece
and the only way to do that was the way
that they did it back in the day which
is actually build the sets Duane and I
walked onto the set one day and we were
like oh my god I was actually nervous
for the studio to see how big was this
is what the film was the designed to
look like I imagined it on the biggest
screen possible and that's the imax
screen it is the only way to see this
movie